sebastián su ga cocina la pasta en la
estufa de gas el café lo calienta en la
placa eléctrica este residente de
colonia en alemania se encuentra ante un
dilema
en el aumento de los precios es una cosa
la otra es que de repente comienzan a
preguntarse de dónde proviene realmente
este gas y comienzas a pensar en
alternativas
cubanas tanto con la anef asanas ma jin
jan no el precio de la energía en
alemania se ha disparado y sus socios
europeos le piden que acabe con la
compra de petróleo y gas a rusia de
donde importa a cerca del 50 por ciento
un problema para muchos alemanes con
menor nivel adquisitivo como recuerda
paolo a limón está habitante también de
colonia
aquí también el gobierno alemán vuelve a
entrar en juego debe cumplir con la
reducción de precios de la energía no si
son capaces de desembolsar 9 mil
millones para lufthansa durante el
coronavirus seguramente podrán
desembolsar 9 mil millones para los
consumidores el gobierno de olaf scholz
se sabe entre la espada y la pared y por
ello pide tiempo a sus socios europeos
la agenda europea pasa por conseguir la
neutralidad climática en 2000 en este
punto no todos son malas noticias para
alemania en la localidad de jal está a
unos 100 kilómetros al norte de colonia
una empresa ha creado una planta
fotovoltaica sobre el lago de una
antigua cantera y acabar en algo de
temor en equipo cuando los precios de la
energía están subiendo las empresas
naturalmente quieren independizarse de
estos precios e invertir en plantas de
este tipo porque aquí podemos generar
electricidad verde en superficies de
agua no utilizadas en 2021 el 42 por
ciento de la energía utilizada en
alemania provenía de energías renovables
según datos oficiales y espera llegar a
la neutralidad climática en 2045 en esta
transición deberá encontrar la forma de
que ningún alemán se quede sin acceso a
la energía